the tyranny of these vaccine mandates
also continues in our nation's capital a
prominent nun is now being denied a
religious exemption from getting the
vaccine and by the way she also has
natural immunity joining me now is
sister deidre burn board certified
family practitioner and surgeon as well
as none and her attorney chris ferrara
special counsel for the thomas more
society
sister byrne wonderful to see you this
evening um
first of all
as a physician have you actually
treated or worked with covid patients
yes um
i've treated a lot of people with early
covert therapy
with
meds that are not easy to get but i've
treated about
400 or more patients we've had excellent
success with keeping people out of the
hospital it's been great
so you also filed a religious exemption
from dc's vaccine mandate beca and you
have moral objections to the vaccines as
do
uh many um religiously motivated people
so
why do you think they rejected your
exemption
i don't know
i don't know it's been
a state of shock when i read the
the
letter
um it's a really good question
well maybe chris your attorney can chime
in on this chris i mean
anyone who knows sister dee dee and i
happen to know her a little bit she's a
woman of great courage and high highly
intelligent and accomplished obviously
she has her reasons but dc said no
well i think you're talking here and
she'll be embarrassed to hear me say
this about the equivalent of mother
teresa for the district of columbia
this is someone who had it all a medical
degree from georgetown university school
of medicine the status of a retired
colonel in the u.s army she could have
had a lucrative career a life of comfort
and privilege and she tossed it all
aside to devote herself to the life of a
religious sister in order to devote it
to providing medical care to the needy
and the undocumented of the district of
columbia so this denial of a religious
exemption
to someone who says quite clearly that
she can have nothing to do
with abortion-connected vaccines
developed from fetal cell lines or
tested from cell lines it's just
inexplicable
the only explanation i can think of is
that this represents yet another example
of the intersection of politics and
bureaucratic intransigence
and religious liberty and the result is
a constitutional train wreck
is there going to be a lawsuit uh
here sister jd oh there you're so you're
you're you've filed the lawsuit already
receiving a temporary restraining order
and you want relief um we hope to get it
by or before march 18th when the denial
of the religious exemption becomes final
and i should say that the form letter
it's apparently a form letter that
denied the exemption request doesn't
dispute the sincerity of sister's
religious beliefs
doesn't dispute her documentation of
those beliefs but instead appears to
have inserted outside of the check boxes
on the form the grounds that to grant
this religious exemption to sister would
be an undue hardship on dc health
meaning the dc health department which
is absurd i mean that's an employment
standard the employer for example says
it would be an undue hardship if you
don't work on sundays but dc health
doesn't employ sister so it makes no
sense it's a made-up criterion for
rejecting the application for exemption
this is
well we have like 30 seconds this is why
tv is hard in moments like this but
sister dede um
we need you out there serving this
community in the dc area we need you
this community needs you more now than
ever so i hope the right thing happens
here but we're going to be praying for
you and for all those who are seeking
exemption
from these types of mandates and thank
you for bringing the story to light hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else